how do you sell your art I'm going to
answer that question in today's episode
of ask Evan
so Risa got asked a question from one of
my youtube viewers love you guys run the
young who wrote in to say I'm an artist
and my passion is creating clay
figurines I live in a very rural area
where such things as artistic figurines
are non-essential items how can I make
them essential Ron that is a fantastic
question I have a soft spot in my heart
for artists and I think on a bigger
scale we're all artists or we should all
be artists of some sort and trying to
make our business grow and so I'm going
to give you three bits of advice that I
think will help you
number one is stand for something
important one of the hardest things
about art is being able to interpret the
art and understand its meaning and have
it have an impact on me and so if you
stand for something important
you have your one word right mine is
believe that gets me a lot of business
if your one word for example was peace
then now I'm not just buying clay
figurines now I'm buying a piece of
peace right so for example you could
design figurines that now have more
meaning to you that are about peace you
could donate a certain percentage of
your profits to peace initiatives around
the world now I feel like I'm buying
into something way bigger than just a
clay figurine and now if I'm looking at
your art your clay figurines versus
buying a mask versus buying a painting
versus buying somebody else's clay
figurines I'm going to go to you first
because I like the mission that you're
on because there's something more
important than just designing clay
figurines so understand what you stand
for
number two is tell your story this is
one of the biggest assets that you have
on an artist and one strategy to think a
lot of artists fall down on is you write
like why are you doing this why do you
love this art what got you started in it
what does each piece that you created
mean right a lot of times again with art
it's hard to understand the meaning and
you're hoping that I come up with a
meaning for it where if you help me
explain the meaning and the deeper
purpose and the angle be
how'd you creating that art right like
you pour a lot of love into every clay
figurine you're making and what whatever
art you're creating a painting picture
whatever there's a lot of love that goes
into it or at least there should be and
so you want to express that tell us a
story behind it
what personal tragedy or excitement or
inspiration led you to want to create
this piece right
that story helps me by in helps me get
connected more to who you are why you're
starting this and it's more likely that
I'm going to buy that piece and then
want to buy more pieces because now I'm
connected to you so tell your story and
number three is get the message out what
I'd start to do is start to look at
connectors start to look at influencers
Sarka look at people who have an
audience whether it's online in social
media or if it's traditional media and
to make that work to get people to talk
about you you have to have the first two
parts down right you have to stand for
something important and you have to have
a story that you can share those people
are going to help spread your message
for you and bring in an audience to help
buy your products so for example if you
sold art that was about believe and you
had a great story about entrepreneurship
your own story I would love to help
promote that right if you sent me
something I would probably hold it up in
one of my videos and want to help share
that message for you give you the
exposure because you're connected with
me who I believe the same thing as you
do right so you want to find people who
are on the same path same mission
they're expressing it through their
YouTube videos who their Twitter
accounts their Instagram profiles you're
expressing it through your art your clay
figurines if you're on the same path and
try to have the same impact then those
are natural collaborations that can
really help you build your business up
but it's not going to happen if you
don't know what you stand for and if
you're not comfortable telling your
story right those connections into the
media into the influencers can really
help take your business to the next step
so remember stand for something
important tell your story and get
the message out good luck Rhonda I hope
that helps you for those of you watching
I'd love to know what advice you have
for artists or maybe if you are an
artist what advice has helped you grow
your business leave it in the comments
below I'm going to join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon